Thanksgiving and Christmas a time to
indulge but for many here in the valley
planning a special holiday dinner
difficult prices continue to climb and
it's hitting food insecure households
Victoria Saha spoke to three square and
other agencies on how they're doing
everything they can to keep up with
increased need this year
while some of the shelves here at three
Square may look empty right now they say
they have another shipment coming in
soon but even that will have to go out
right away to make sure families don't
go without food this holiday season
volunteers at three Square are busy
packing up the many boxes of food going
out to the community
director Amanda jersic says their recent
data shows one in seven people struggle
with hunger in our area I haven't ever
seen it this bad it's been this hard for
people to be able to afford their own
food for this Thanksgiving many families
will not have a traditional holiday meal
Three Square says they had to make a
tough choice between spending money on a
single turkey or buying a week's worth
of groceries for families the food bank
distributes to more than 160 food
pantries in southern Nevada but the need
this year is like any other they need
more food they need more food and we are
just doing our best to make sure that we
have enough food here it goes in and it
goes out as fast as it comes in Catholic
Charities gets a supply from Three
Square lines for their Pantry were out
the door Monday we're surviving but um
it's just a little bit of an extra
struggle I'm not ashamed to say if I
have to go to the food bank I go to the
food bank it does help a lot to meet the
need Leslie Carmine with Catholic
Charities says they are reevaluating how
much they're giving out there may have
been times where that box of food was
very Hefty maybe 80 pounds of food at
one time now it's maybe shrinking a
little bit they say this year they had
people asking for help for the first
time Victoria Saha eight news now
Catholic Charities accepts donations any
items that can help make a few meals go
a long way such as canned protein pastas
and of course peanut butter that's right
and of course if you want to help out we
have posted information on our website
8newsnow.com